the australian open tennis tournament
which starts monday and it is still
unclear whether the men's world number
one will be playing novak djokovic's
visa was revoked yesterday for a second
time by the australian authorities the
dispute over his vaccine status has now
overshadowed the tournament's
preparations for 10 days roxanna seberry
is in our london bureau with the latest
roxanna good morning
good morning dana well the standoff
continues but we may finally know
tomorrow whether djokovic will stay and
defend his title or be forced to fly out
of australia
detained again but novak djokovic is
refusing to accept defeat
the serbian tennis star is set to argue
at a court hearing tomorrow against the
australian government's order to deport
him with the tournament just days away
the immigration minister revoked his
visa on health and good order grounds
because djokovic is unvaccinated they
believe that him remaining in australia
would exercise or incite
anti-vaccination sentiment more so than
if he were to be kicked out he's already
winning the support of some
anti-vaccination campaigners in
melbourne
the contrast with his victory last year
couldn't be clearer
in the drawn-out drama just to enter the
country this year djokovic admitted his
agent gave incorrect information on his
immigration form
and that he took part in an interview
and photo shoot despite knowing he
tested positive for covet 19.
in a country that's seen some of the
world's toughest lockdowns and
vaccinated over 90 of adults his actions
have sparked an outcry do you think
australians will be happy to see him go
in general
i think a lot of people will be happy
that the the saga is over whichever way
it plays out one of djokovic's biggest
rivals agrees if he's playing finally
okay if he's not playing
australian open will be a great
australian open
with or without him
if djokovic loses his appeal in court
tomorrow he'd likely be deported right
away and he could be barred from
re-entering the country for another
three years dana
all right roxanna we will stay tuned
thank you